Bruno Darou on le sait le chemin sera
long pour Kiev vers l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne en tout cas là Charles Michel
et Ursula van derline ont été très
clairs ça va vraisemblablement arriver
en tout cas aussi rapidement que
possible voilà tout est en fait dans le
aussi rapidement que possible là où tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord en fait
c'est sur le rythme en fait d'adhésion
de l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne est-ce
qu'on fait une exception pour l'Ukraine
comparée aux autres pays candidats
est-ce que donc on va plus vite pour
arrimer véritablement l'Ukraine à la
famille européenne évidemment les
Ukrainiens sont pour un rythme très
rapide certains pays européens sont un
peu plus réticents notamment parce qu'il
faut quand même que pour certains
critères l'Ukraine soit au niveau en
fait mais ça encore on peut peut-être
faire une exception après il y a aussi
le fait que 18% du territoire
ukrainien est occupé par un État
étranger en l'occurrence la Russie et ce
serait je crois une première de faire
adhérer un pays à l'Union européenne
dont une partie du territoire est
occupée voilà pourquoi aussi certains
pensent qu'il faut peut-être un petit
peu patienter envoyer le signal ce qui a
été fait là l'Ukraine et l'Europe sont
voilà la même famille même communauté de
valeur clairement donc c'est une défense
aussi du modèle démocratique contre le
modèle autoritaire incarné par Vladimir
Poutine c'est ce modèle là qui va
l'emporter parce qu'il est fondé sur des
valeurs saines en quelque sorte les
valeurs les valeurs démocratiques
mais pour
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne en fait le cap est fixé tôt
ou tard l'Ukraine fera partie de l'Union
européenne et comme la souligné Charles
Michel c'était pas gagné au début quand
il fallait accepter que l'Ukraine soit
candidate et candidat il y avait
beaucoup de scepticisme on a avancé
l'objectif final et ben c'est que
l'Ukraine va rejoindre l'Union
européenne toute la question qui demeure
quand même c'est quand à quel rythme
selon quel modalité voilà c'est le débat
qui va qui va qui va se poursuivre mais
on aura le lancement des négociations si
on a bien compris à l'automne prochain
il y aura un rapport de la Commission
européenne et cette adhésion progressive
plus ou moins progressive voilà de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne sera
alors vraiment lancée merci beaucoup
Bruno pour votre éclairage voilà